hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong where today's
episode features a super special guest
i'm your host mark ellison i am the host
of the show this week my esteemed
colleague the better half of this
program jacqueline coley is doing one of
the many things that she does great
she's covering a film festival she's a
telluride film festival i don't even
know what state that's in but i know
that she's hard at work not just
watching movies she's reviewing them
she's putting scrutiny towards art and
she's also writing a bunch of articles
and she's doing some interviews a whole
lot of stuff most of which you can check
out at
rottentomatoes.com i highly encourage
everybody to follow her on her adventure
to telluride or really any film festival
not only she great at covering it but if
you've ever had the experience of being
jacqueline coley's plus one at a film
festival party a shindig a hoot nanny
you had a good time i know from
experience so we're down to jaclyn this
week but we are up like i said a very
special guest who has very
opinionated takes on many movies not the
least of which is the 2007
cult classic i can say
hot rod that's what we're talking about
this week hot rod starring andy samberg
and it's a movie i had never seen before
and what a trip i was in for i didn't
know the cast was this extensive i
didn't know much about this movie and i
didn't know that people still cared
about it to this day but i should have
because ever since the movie came out
i've had people from all walks of my
life my comedian friends my pals from
high school from middle school from
kindergarten they all shout from the
rooftops how have you not seen hot rod
yet and i had never seen it until last
night in preparation for this episode
now hot rod despite a lot of my friends
his love for it is rotten on the tomato
meter it's 39 rotten it does recover on
the audience score because it's 64 which
is fresh there so that's some good news
for all you
hot radites out there
let's talk about our guest it's somebody
who
you probably heard of because he is one
of the biggest music stars on the planet
chance the rapper is here today to talk
about hot rod and we'll see where the
conversation wants to take us because
jacqueline and myself thanks to our good
pal eric davis got to have a twitter
spaces conversation with chance the
rapper not too long ago and we talked
about a bunch of different movies
including his new concert film
magnificent coloring world it just
finished its run here in the states very
successful two-week engagement in about
80-85 theaters across the country and
now it's expanding to the uk to ireland
and to canada starting september 10th
and i can just tell you all you need to
see this in a theater if you have the
means check it out in a theater you
don't want to wait for this one because
the stage the setup he put so much care
and concern and craft into making this
self-funded concert film they taped it a
few years ago it's finally out and you
can check it out and it is a concert
film unlike any other i've seen a lot of
them i'm a pretty big music fan never
seen anything close to magnificent
coloring world so we're going to talk
about that and hot rod with chance the
rapper just a little bit but if you're
wondering hey mark i've heard of hot rod
i think it's got those lonely island
guys associated with it you're right and
let's keep going on that path with what
the hell is hot rod about well you have
this guy
who's a stunt performer and he's played
by andy samberg and he just doesn't have
all the luck in the world his name's rob
kimble and he just wants to be a
stuntman like he thinks his dad was and
not only does one to be a stunt man for
himself and to impress his buddies and a
new love interest played by iowa fisher
he also wants to show his stepdad that
he is a man his stepdad is played by ian
mcshane and he's married to andy
sandberg's mom in the film played by
none other than [ __ ] spacek yes that's
[ __ ] spacex that ian mcshane are in hot
rod you also get jacqueline coley's
favorite bill hader one of my favorites
danny mcbride and a host of other
notable poppins in this movie it's an
adventure it's a comedy it's ridiculous
and is it funny is it good does it stand
the test of time some 15 years after its
release gonna talk about that with
myself and chance the rapper in just a
little bit producer lucy's here brian
perez our esteemed engineer is here and
before we get to chance let's go to our
expert review curation manager tim ryan
for our segment where he's going to tell
us what the critics were saying
at the time about hot rod and i don't
believe it's going to be all that kind
tim
it's all yours
it's a common complaint among critics
and audiences that movies from saturday
night live alums are often based on
premises that might kill as five-minute
sketches but are stretched pretty thin
over feature lengths and that's pretty
much what critics said about hot rod
that it had a few big laughs but
couldn't sustain much comic momentum
it's also worth noting that more than a
few reviewers felt the movie compared
unfavorably to one of the best gags from
napoleon dynamite it's rotten at 39 on
the tomato meter with a 64 audience
score
so what did the critics have to say in a
rotten review peter debrosh of variety
wrote those hoping for feature-length
doses of sandberg's lazy sunday wit will
have to settle for just plain lazy as
hot rod aims low and still manages to
miss the target
however in a fresh review alonzo duralde
of msnbc wrote hotrod emerges as a daffy
dorky summer surprise a silly comedy of
non-sequiturs that feels like a cockeyed
collaboration between will ferrell and
mel brooks the rt critic's consensus
reads hot rod has brazen silliness and a
few humorous set pieces on its side but
it's far too inconsistent to satisfy all
but the least demanding slapstick lovers
so that's hot rod let's kick it back to
those death-defying podcast daredevils
back to you folks thank you tim and yeah
they were not nice to that movie that
may have been one of the reasons why i
never waddled my way to the theater to
see hot rod despite some nice reviews
from my pals is
um
the critics really did not like this
movie and you had a bunch of other
comedies coming out in 2007 that it
unfortunately had to compete with and so
a lot of factors against hot rod but it
has become a cult classic since then
going to talk with chance the rapper
about that in just a few seconds but i
am hosting the show today so i should
remind you that currently i'm in las
vegas and i got a couple more dates here
at the mgm grand that you all can come
check out i'll be in new york at new
york comedy club and popping into some
other places around the big apple in
october i also have san francisco
arizona washington dc and los angeles my
adopted home on the schedule you get
tickets at mark ellis dot live or at
whatever comedy club i'm at follow me on
social media most of the answers are
right there but enough about me
let's talk to one of the biggest stars
on the planet he is chance the rapper
i'm just the guy lucky enough to
interview him about hot rod
[Music]
and so we are down a jacqueline coley
who is attending to her very busy duties
at the telluride film festival but we
are up our special guest whose movie
magnificent coloring world just finished
a very successful national 14-day run at
theaters here in the states and it's
going to be releasing in the uk ireland
and canada on september 10th so
everybody who's in our ketchup crew in
those parts of the world go check out
magnificent coloring world because it is
an amazing spectacle you should witness
on the big screen and the star and
creator of it is right here right now
chance the rapper hey
good to catch up with you again bud what
a magnificent introduction thank you i
mean you know i practiced in my mirror
for a couple hours this morning and and
we had such a fun time connecting on
twitter spaces so we're like well we
might as well do it on the podcast
because you are such a a cinephile and
you can kind of see it with magnificent
coloring world how your your cinematic
influences but you also really were
striving to do something different and
original and i think you i think you hit
it out of the park how does it feel to
have that movie come out and have such a
great critical reception after it's
united states run it's an amazing field
man i i
i think you know this everybody doesn't
necessarily know it the movie's been
around in different uh formats for a
long time for four years we shot it in
2017 and uh it's gone through many edits
in many different formats and and now
it's finally in its finished form and
and i love it and it and you know like
you said it feels it feels amazing to
have a great critical response and
you know to see the fanfare around it
it's just really cool completion of that
feel very complete and it feels very
fresh too because it's not like there's
so many times when you when you hear
about movies and they were sitting on
the shelf for six months or a year and
you're like oh no what's going on with
this but no this this feels like you
recorded it yesterday i mean it's just
got such a such a fresh magnetic energy
and the audience is so into and the
stage is great i could talk about this
movie all day but before we get into
more in-depth stuff which i do want to
get back into with magnificent coloring
world we got to talk about this movie
that you suggested that we cover on our
podcast i have never seen this movie
until i got home from the comedy store
late last night i
i'm not gonna lie i had a couple beers
and i watched hot rod for the very first
time so hot rod right now it's 39
percent
rotten
on the tomato meter
and that does not please the court of
chance the rapper it is 60
64 of the audience score so that's fresh
there but chance i imagine your feelings
on hot rod's tomato meters score
you probably think it's like travis is
wrong yeah it doesn't it's uh
doesn't do uh it does a disservice to
all the work that uh you know andy
sandberg and all those comedic geniuses
put into that fine piece of cinema and
uh
yes it uh it upsets me and
it just doesn't feel right
okay so
why
is the score way too low and what do you
think the score for hot rod
should be
um those are two great questions i'm
going to start by answering the easier
question that uh the answer is it should
be a 100
if not a 101 or a 110 uh it covers all
the bases uh it has a great great
character arcs for each person in the
movie uh you know there's great acting
uh from andy sandberg um amongst a host
of other characters uh i think uh that
will arnetta's in the movie will arnett
th the cast really impressed me with
this movie because you i knew andy
sandberg was there i knew it was like a
lonely island sort of
brainchild but then you have [ __ ]
spacek is in it ian mcshane is in it
danny mcbride bill hader who jacqueline
my my beloved co-host she is she fawns
over bill hader every chance she gets
and so she was extra bummed to not get
to gush about him with you we are going
to get jaclyn's thoughts on the movie
too later on in the show but yeah i mean
the cast is amazing and just as somebody
who like i said i'd never seen it before
the good news to report is rotten
tomatoes is dead wrong about this movie
because this movie had me
from
the opening
frame
and i love when comedies can do that
this movie it just what was the first
time you saw hot rod tell me about that
experience what what that was like i
think i saw hot rod not in theaters
actually which um was doing myself a
disservice i think the first time i saw
it was probably
i think with my girlfriend with my wife
now but when my girl i think uh i think
the year it came out we got it like uh
like on an on-demand service and just
felt like we had been gifted
a a great responsibility and
understanding and deciphering like i
said the comedic genius of andy sandberg
dana mcbride bill hader all these great
comedic acts put together this movie
about following your dreams
about the importance of of uh of stunt
workers and community and uh and just
all these all these great lessons and
just just it's just a it's just a great
experience to to see the movie and i
think it's inspired by some some of the
great cinematic accomplished
accomplishments of the 20th century
godfather and
casino and uh citizen kane just it's in
a it's in the pantheon of of um of
amazing cinematic accomplishments and
when we saw it for the first time we
just couldn't
help but appreciate it you know what did
somebody recommend it to you did did
somebody turn you say did you have to
see this movie or was it just you're
just kind of scrolling what's on vod and
you found hot rod
do you believe in divinity
you believe in
destiny
yeah i can get there that's how i that's
how i found it it was kind of just like
my thumb
just kept pressing and i was like i
think i saw what i what i needed already
but i just kept going
and then you see andy on that on that uh
and with the cape and everything and
it just feels like it feels like it's
kind of calling you yeah the fake
mustache got me but so i love when
comedies let you know exactly what
you're in for for the duration of the
movie within the first frame so i think
about another movie that came out in
1994 ace ventura pet detective the first
time we saw jim carrey that first scene
of him working for hds and he's
delivering a package and he's just being
jim carrey on the street it's exactly
what the rest of that movie is going to
feel like so you're either in or you're
out right from the start and with hot
rod one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is just that opening sequence
where we see him attempting this stunt
and it just goes horribly
horribly wrong i was already laughing i
do this thing now this old man thing
where if i sit down and something
tickles me and i'm in my apartment it's
just me and the dog i slapped my knee
and that continued to happen throughout
the rest of hot rod that's what the
[ __ ] love
it's a knee slapper
it's a uh
it's a it's a punch in the gut belly
laugh you know it's a lot of slapstick
also so you can tell that they were
influenced by the greats the charlie
chaplins of the world there's a whole
scene in the movie i think it lasts for
probably no less than six minutes of
andy sandberg falling down a mountain
and
very little dialogue
uh it's just him falling one of the
greatest scenes in any movie of all time
we have a great researcher here on the
show that uh his name is mark hoffmeyer
and i think that he tabulated that scene
last over like 43 seconds of just pure
pure falling and then you have that
scene then you also have the scene that
my mom is going to love because my mom's
one of my mom's favorite like
terms to quote is cool beans cool beans
and the cool beans
great
for it's one of the best scenes in the
movie yeah no by far cool cool beans
it's just a the movie is non-stop i feel
like that's like you know there there's
there's movies that you go to because
they have a singular great scene or
great dialogue there's movies that you
go to because there's a twist ending
there's movies
that you know you go to because there's
an overall message but i like
entertaining movies you know what i mean
something that that grips me from the
moment that i get in and all the way
through the satisfying end and that's
what hot rod is yeah i like how you
describe this movie as really hitting
you on two different levels where it
hits your funny bone for sure but then
it also is
somewhat of an inspiration i mean if
you're going to embark on a career like
yours you it's it's you're taking a big
risk you're
you're you're sacrificing what a lot of
people would consider to be a normal
line of life because you have this dream
that you want to chase so what is a
scene in hot rod for you that typifies
that that goes it can be comedic for
sure but it's that scene where you say
oh no this guy's a dreamer you know
chasing after a lifelong goal just like
i am there's a scene where uh where andy
is uh andy's character is is getting
ready to to jump the pool i think it is
and uh and he enlists the help of like
his team and also this this really weird
guy that likes to like hump the air i
don't know really what his deal is but
he enlists like these this this
community of misfits to to help him hand
the hand um pass out fires and promote
this this this crazy jump that's going
to be like the pinnacle of his career so
far hey
denise hey looks exciting is there
anything i can do to help oh no that's
cool
i think my crew's got it pretty much
covered
so
good luck
don't worry denise
i've done this before
and it's and it's hilarious and it's
edited well and it's and and like i said
it just hits these beats of continuous
you know laughter but it also really
reminds me of how it was in the
beginning like i come from i come from
open mics i come from talent shows i'm i
come from radio contests like i'm the
type of dude that like i didn't find out
that i was like that i wanted to start
rapping and two weeks later i got famous
you know like i wanted to be a rapper
since i was probably 11 years old since
kanye west dropped a college dropout and
so since then i was writing rap since i
was 14 i was going to studios and
you know when it comes to to doing to to
doing an event to like whether it's a
talent show that you're selling tickets
for or your own show that you're selling
tickets for you're trying to promote
it's like it always comes down to you
having like a small group of people
around you that are weirdos and misfits
that actually believe that you could be
something and and them going around and
putting their actual
sweat and energy and hard work into
promoting you and i just always was like
that's me you know i'm right that's
such an enlightening take on that
pulsing because watching it last night
the scariest thing about that scene for
me is not that he's going to attempt
this stunt that he's going to try to
jump a pool it's that he invited the the
whole town is there and this is
everybody that he knows because i come
from the world of doing open mics as far
as doing stand-up goes but i had the
luxury being a comic where i was in
north carolina at the time i drove to
atlanta to do my first slew of open mics
because i did not want anybody that i
knew would be there in the crowd i
wanted to do it for strangers because if
you bomb in front of strangers they'll
they'll forget the next day you bomb in
front of your friends they're going to
let you know the rest of your life did
you have that luxury i imagine if you're
if you're do if you're a musician if
you're in a studio you and you have a
crew you probably have people that if
you don't do well your very first time
out they're gonna let you know about it
oh totally
yeah
and that's that's what uh danny
mcbride's character is there for he's
kind of like
this sucks that's like his that's his
where he's at the whole movie
it's he's he's one of my f like danny
mcbride is just one of those guys that
just he has the direct line to my funny
bone and he just makes me laugh even
when he's not the star of the scene
there's a scene about halfway through
the movie where andy and and iowa fisher
are sort of connecting but then will
arnett's character shows up for the
first time and in the background they're
outside a convenience store and in the
in the background bill
mcbride dancing it's the funniest thing
yeah and daniel bryan's like slamming
the the brother into like the the car
and stuff he's just like
[Music]
so
how do you like being in the crew so far
it's been interesting
i told you
[Music]
hey denise
is there something i wanted to ask you
yeah
well
i couldn't help but notice that
we've both matured a lot
physically
and i was just wondering
hey rod what's that song called about
the grandma getting run over by reindeer
he has a another great scene well
they're all great in the scene where uh
where their first meeting uh isla
fisher's character and they go around in
a circle they're supposed to introduce
themselves rod starts off hi i'm rod and
i like to party and each person
afterwards says their name and then says
that they like to party i'm pretty sure
danny's character goes i'm rod and i
like to party it's just a good it's just
a great scene hey everybody
we got some awesome news we have a new
crew member today denise
hi everyone
so i thought it'd be fun if we all went
around and said our name a little
something about ourselves i'll start
my name is rod
and i like to party
all right dave you're up uh hi uh my
name is dave
and uh
i
like to party uh no dave i just said
that i partied so maybe do something
different for me
my name is dave and i
am the stuntman you know what let's move
on rico you're up uh hello i'm rico and
i like to party yeah uh rico what did i
just say to dave who dave i like to
party i'm rod no you're kevin right
kevin everything in the movie i swear to
you for anyone that hasn't seen it and
is and is being repelled from seeing it
by seeing this this terrible score that
it received please watch this movie
please do yourself a favor and the
people around you a favor and call a
movie night an emergency meeting movie
night and share this joy with each other
i think it warrants that level i think
it is an emergency now your friends are
probably going to think that you're
having an intervention for you or
something but they're not they just
really it's a bit of an intervention
it is an intervention in a way because
if you haven't seen hot rod and again
i'm the last guy to jump on this train
or dirt bike as the case may be and tell
y'all that it is one of the it's one of
the funniest movies that i've seen and
one of the reasons why is because the
entire cast from andy all the way down
is just so note perfect in it besides
andy samberg's lead character who was
the character that you were like that's
that's my person in this movie that's a
good question
i think
the next person down
is probably
rod's stepfather
yes so there's like this b story going
on the whole time one of the things
that's driving
rod to
to do all of this in this limited amount
of time he's trying to prove himself as
uh as a real stunt man and not just as a
real stunt man that's actually the key
to it as a real man because
his
mother's
new husband
is dying of uh i can't even remember an
unknown sickness um but he's got a bad
heart he's got a new heart he's got to
get a new heart it's been a little while
since i've seen the movie but you could
tell it's pretty fresh on my mind
sometimes when we do movies it's like
i've never seen them sometimes like hot
right but then there's other times i've
seen the movie so many times we actually
did ace ventura on this show a while
back and like i didn't have to rewatch
that movie i it's it's just it's in
there
yeah ian mcshane as the as the
stepfather is it is it is one of those b
storylines that does permeate the rest
of the movie because you're pulling for
he's the he's sort of the impetus for me
to root for andy sandberg's character
even more because you want him to prove
it but ian mcshane is so perfect in that
movie because he's this classically
trained actor and so he never gets to
the point where you actually hate him
you enjoy the scenes but he's not like
just this wicked stepmother from
cinderella that you hope get their
comeuppance you actually just want him
to
you want both of them to come together
as a family no it's very carefully acted
the
the cool thing is that andy
hates his stepdad
uh but he also still wants to honor and
impress his his stepdad so there's a
scene where uh i think uh the stepfather
like calls him like calls him close to
his ear and tells him he's still or
something like that
and andy turns around and uh and like
screams is his face something along the
lines of like
i need you to get better so i can beat
your ass it's like i can't remember what
he said but something along the lines of
like don't die because i need to beat
the body
it's a really cool
you know dynamic between the two of them
because it's like you said you
you you know you don't you're not
rooting for the step dad but you want
him to stay healthy healthy enough
so that rod
can beat the dog out of him yeah and i'm
just trying to think back on like all
the stunts in this movie because there
you do have to give a major props to the
stunt crew that worked on this movie
because they pull off some stuff it's
supposed to not go well and the scene at
the end where he's trying to jump all
these these buses it's
it like it's a real stunt and and it
plays from a stunt standpoint but also a
comedic standpoint did you have one
favorite stunt with big or small that
you're like that is that's what you can
tell the care that they put into making
this movie yeah there's a scene when
they're going when uh when rod is going
down
this hill on a
on like a i think it's like a boogie
board or something it might be it might
be a small like uh like car makeshift
car that they put together but i just
remember he's going down this hill um on
this really poorly engineered
vehicle of some sort and
spoiler he loses control and
and and
face plants
as hard as you possibly can into the
side of this bus
it looks like andy did that
like to me
you know the scene of him going down is
just like probably like a
a dolly on the board or whatever like
when they're going down the hill and it
looks like he's going really fast
but it could you know it could be
whatever he could be any place when he
hits the bus though
you you feel it as an audience member
and again i was talking about those
those gut-wrenching belly laughs where
you're just like oh my god i can't
believe i just saw this happen that was
one of those moments for me
and then the scene just ups to annie
after that danny brooke bride beats
this random dude like it's just like it
like i said it's a
continuous laugh what was the what was
the rating again on this
uh it's uh unfortunately it is 39
right yeah
so i hate to do this but let's just
cross reference for a second
another movie right there's another
movie that was released in the i think
it was in the late 90s it might have
been early 2000s but i'm almost 100 sure
late night
written directed and starring warren
beatty it's a film called
bullworth
yeah he's a politician yeah do you
remember bullworth i remember hearing
about bullworth and it being this sort
of touchstone movie but i don't know
that i ever actually saw bullworth but
i'm i'm looking it up right now and so
i'm going to give you the rotten
tomatoes score for rotten tomatoes let's
see the explorer on board do you think
it's a fresh movie on rotten tomatoes
let's not let's not ruin it yet let's
find out first what what our what what
it's clocking in at
for our critical reception
and then i will and then and then i'll
i'll spoil it for you all right here's
your number for bullworth
one more time just a refresher for the
what were we at on hot rod was that 37
39
39
rotten rating
and bullworth almost doubles it because
bulworth is certified fresh 76
on the tomato meter okay and now i will
tell you guys it's probably
it's probably the worst movie
ever made cross
across every metric
um
anybody that sees this movie
you know should know even if it was the
90s no excuse that this is possibly the
most trash piece of cinema ever put
together
it excels in racism it's got it's it's
got it's
flying colors in in racism terrible
dialogue shot horrifically acted
terribly from some great actors
warren beatty i still respect you i
guess um halle berry are one of the
greatest actresses uh of any time first
black woman to ever win uh academy award
but it's also like i said one of the
worst acted movies in the world and
that's probably because it has
objectively the worst
worst script i've ever ever seen put
together by human hands i don't know who
wrote it down
i hope they're in prison this is like
this is like two shows in one because we
get your take and you get rotten
tomatoes as being wrong because they're
rotten on hot rod and then rotten
tomatoes has the certification of
bullworth being fresh and you think
that's wrong too i don't want to
exclusively give the blame to run
because rotten wasn't around i don't
think when this movie came out it's just
an aggregator yeah they pulled together
the critical reception but they also
pulled together the audience reception
what was the audience reception on this
on this travesty it's a little higher
than hot rod it's 68 percent to hot rod
64 percent so i do like seeing the jump
from hot rod getting the uh finding its
audience and bulworth not quite as warm
with the audience as it was with the
critics i'm still disappointed in all 68
of you
um
what
the [ __ ] happened with this film i'll
give you guys just because there's some
people who have never even seen bulwark
they're like why is this guy trash in
this movie is probably great i'll give
you a short analysis of the movie the
movie is about this guy who's uh you
know basically on his way to becoming
president he's a uh this older white guy
that's that's very removed and but has
been known to be
a democratic and more progressive
politician over the years and it starts
off the movie the movie opens with like
a uh
you know this pan across his dresser of
photoshop
pictures of him with mlk and jesse
jackson and al sharpton and stuff like
that but over time he's become more cold
and more conservative and he basically
hires a hit man to kill him so he can
get some insurance money for his for his
family and then i don't really remember
what it is what's the catalyst if he
hits his head or if he watches a rap
music video but for the rest of the film
warren beatty um employs a a black scent
which is a black accent for people that
don't know and delivers all the rest of
his dialogue and rhyming raps that are
extremely condescending to all black
people it's one of the most
heinous things to ever happen on camera
for an hour and a half it's so
disturbing when you watch it you will
not believe that this is a real movie i
remember it i remember when it came out
i remember when when the movie came out
and tell me what critics were
celebrating it because they felt like
this was this you know movie that that
cross crosses cultures and and it's
going to be this uniting bridge of a
movie but it seems like it's one of
those films that maybe it didn't hit
with everyone at the time and when you
look at it 20 years later you're like
what were we doing
yeah yeah we should
build a time machine and go back to them
and tell them that racism didn't stop
because of this movie it actually got
worse and uh and
and warren beatty we should go back and
and catch him in the act of patting
himself on the back after the movie was
released and grab his arm and say don't
you
dare pat that back this is the worst
thing to ever happen to anybody and yeah
i just hope that i hope that
even just through this discussion that
somehow
somehow my my takedown of the movie goes
viral and we can start to see clips you
know re-emerge from the movie just so
that people can can can feel this
dialogue that i had to that i had to
watch and that i've you know put other
people through just to show them an
example of what not to do when
discussing race in film but i say all
that to say
the critical consensus on a movie
can be wrong
when aggregated the the the audience
is
very uh receptive to whatever to a lot
of times to what the critics have to say
because that's a lot of times their
first
impression of the movie
and you know
rule of thumb you might not want to
write direct and star in a movie because
then who's telling you that this is
terrible you need someone to say no you
need a good idea
fill in one of those those categories
with somebody else yeah we always get
mad at studios when they meddle in
movies that we think are going to be
masterpieces but we never give the
studios credit when they step in and say
hey warren babe maybe just star in this
and let somebody else figure out what
the movie's going to be yeah we'll burn
this film
yeah yeah it's it we should go back
we'll go back further than than bull
we'll go back to like the early 90s when
he was making bugsy and we'll let him
make bugsy and then we'll be like all
right dude you're knocking this out of
the park just there's this bullworth
movie just don't even don't even look at
it it's going to be crash before crash
was the thing
it is the first crash it was the first
it was it was crash zero it was patient
zero for crash
but that's why we have the show i mean
that's why
basically what i'm hearing from you is
that rotten tomatoes is wrong should
have been around as a radio program on
npr or something in the 90s where we
talked about it we could have
yeah
but this is not the limit of your of
your opinions on movies because look i
told everybody listening and watching
chance is a huge movie fan you also i
believe came on our rotten tomatoes
radar initially not because of bull
worth or because of hot rod
the house is another comedy that you
love that is its chance i hate to say
this it's 20
on the tomato meter what's going on with
that
that movie
is worth
i don't know how many bull words
actually i don't even want to put it in
bull words because
those are negative points so right right
more words
that means it was like super super
offensive yeah no it was uh
it's just a it's a good movie
i don't i don't i wouldn't call it the
greatest
comedy
of all time like i would hot rod or some
you know some of the other greats but
it was one of those bottom of the barrel
movies that i just happened to find you
know i damn near found it on dvd and i
was like
when did amy poehler and will ferrell
star in a movie together i never heard
of this thing even happening
and
i watched it
and i didn't just enjoy it i thoroughly
enjoyed it i thought it was hilarious i
thought it was a cool idea i thought it
was a funny contained film you know
it's it's uh
it deals with something real which is
families trying to figure out how in the
they're going to pay for their kids to
go to college and does all these cool
contrasts of
you know what
the
ideal suburban life is versus like what
people will do to to take care of their
kids and it's it's really really funny
but i also found out that there's like
just since we're talking about the
formula of rotten tomatoes there's a lot
of politics that that go into
any industry but definitely the movie
industry and i actually have read before
that
critics expect a certain
structure and
certain formalities when it comes to
reviewing a film one of those key things
being invited for special pre-screeners
or advanced screenings that are private
and for the critics so that the critics
can have a preview of the movie along
with a review of the movie before it
hits theaters and i read that the house
didn't hold any screenings for the
critics um and that they saw it at the
same time as regular audiences
and that that that might have had
something to do with it getting 20
because how else do you give this movie
20
i have never seen the movie full
disclosure because there were no
pre-screenings for it i remember that i
was on the road in houston the movie the
the day the movie came out and
and i was working the improv there and
there was just no time for me during the
day because i was sleeping late and
waking up to write and then go do the
shows so i never got a chance to see the
house but it's an interesting comparison
to hot rod simply because you're talking
about
a bunch of saturday night live stars of
the last two decades right you have amy
poe or will ferrell in the house and
then you have andy sandberg and bill
hader and company in hot rod do you have
a favorite like an all-time favorite
saturday night live cast member who
would be like your your murderers row of
snl performers past and present you
start off with keenan thompson because
he's the reason why the show's
been
successful in the past uh 13 years
you
give flowers to
tina fey amy poehler
kristen wiig
uh maya
fred that the whole like uh
20 like
2007 through
2014 cast is just
phenomenal and then all my friends that
are at snl now and that that have been
there and left uh back bennett
you know i mean like it's the whole
thing is like everybody
i would say the vast majority of
people that that work at snl at some
point become comedy legends so like i'm
not saying any of that to like
you know
to skip over eddie murphy and
dan aykroyd
all
there's all these legends obviously from
the 70s and 80s that are just
you know forever legends but uh yeah the
the the cat i started going on snl when
i was
22 i'm 27
i'm 28 now yeah i was going to say you
performed on snl right yeah so i've done
that what's that experience like because
we we kind of know what it's like
because we've heard the stories of
hosting snl
where you're an actor and you show up
and you go through and and you have you
kind of pair off with some writers and
they write some stuff for you as far as
being the musical guest on the show what
is that experience like what's that week
like is it just one long whirlwind yeah
well i mean
for me i'm a i'm a real fan of snl like
i've been that way since i was probably
eight years old because my cousin had a
video recording of m.c hammer being
the guest
performer as well as the guest host
speaking enough too to quit and yeah
yeah too legit too legit to quit
i he uh he was the first person that i
had seen
do the show
and so in my mind it was always like
when i get on the show i'm gonna
i'm gonna be the musical guest but i'm
also gonna be the host you know and
there's a lot of like
you know it's a historical institution
they have ways of like you know you go
through different things so i started
off i just performed and i think the
next day next time i came i just
performed then my third time coming
because i have been begging lauren and i
have been you know when you're the
musical guest that was a good question
you don't really come to the to the
building you're not at 8h except for on
thursday
friday and saturday for the actual
taping but when you're the host you're
there the whole week so for i've known
that because i have snl books so for my
first time coming i would try and
basically break into the building from
the sunday that they start and the first
time i came there i met uh a still a
good friend of mine um
uh pete
uh pete davidson
um and we met on twitter or whatever i
was like yo i'm in new york i'm just
trying to come up there and he let me
into the building it was a monday so
uh artists are not supposed to be there
and i ended up kicking it with him uh
uh keenan and um and leslie um in their
room just like smoking weed and just
like hearing stories and understanding
like how the whole thing works and kind
of just like plotting on how i'm gonna
get on the show in a meaningful way not
to say that
being a musical guest isn't extremely
meaningful it's like there's a huge you
know legacy to that but like i said like
i love i'm from chicago i used to do
improv i you know i
you know chicago is kind of
you know that's where they get all of
these people from a lot of these people
start off in second city and then they
move and they get picked up for for snl
so yeah most snl legends that people
know started at second city in chicago
right literally right around you exactly
so like i always had the dream of you
know everybody from chicago thinks
they're funny so i always wanted to be a
comedian i always wanted to you know
eventually do comedic acting and like do
something so from the jump i'm like man
i want to be on the show so i basically
met them um i tried to come in a couple
more days that week and i remember
famously getting told like they don't
want you to come up here because you're
just the musical guest next time i came
i did the same thing and i actually
ended up being in a random sketch i had
like one line i said something about
like uh
i got frankincense and myrrh that's what
that was my line uh
you're doing a run on the wise man yeah
exactly i was on the i was i was one of
the three wise men so it's the only
thing it's the only thing people know
from frankincense and myrrh it's like oh
well they got to be talking about the
wise men that's literally i've never
heard of those two substances outside of
that context i didn't even know what
they were until i did the sketch so like
i basically
wedged my way in there shoehorned my way
into the into a sketch and they liked my
stuff they said i had hutzpah i had the
the you know what it takes and the next
time i came up there uh lauren asked me
to be the host no musical guest spot and
that and i learned how grueling that
schedule really is because they they
shoot at least two sketches are usually
taped so they're on location and it's
usually freezing or just like at the ass
crack of dawn or at the in the middle of
the night that you're shooting and then
you know there's constant rehearsals
constant writing um
but when i came up there because i was
so excited i wrote five sketches uh
ahead of time that me and my writing
partner rhys put together and three of
them actually made it to taping and two
of them actually aired and wow yeah
prepared i came i came super prepared i
like i said i came from i used to do
improv i used to you know a lot of my
friends did second city and
um and so like i've always loved you
know writing and and especially comedic
writing so we had one sketch that was um
just funny just a dumb idea was just
this idea of uh
you know steve harvey has uh uh in the
sketch steve harvey has an illegitimate
son that comes on with uh with a with uh
a white family he's a and uh and steve
harvey over the course of the of the
episode
recognizes that it's his illegitimate
fun
it's funny in like an impression kind of
way i'm doing an impression of keenan's
impression of steve harvey and that
played really well and then the other
one was a little smarter it was uh
it was funny i actually had help from
donald glover on right and the other one
was uh wayne thanksgiving so it's uh
bruce wayne is hosting a a a
thanksgiving turkey giveaway and uh
and all the people that come in you know
because he's so wealthy and powerful
they're like oh yeah thank you for the
for the turkey but we want to talk to
could you do something about batman he's
a menace he's just
brutalizing random civilians it's like i
i did the the smallest petty crime and
he beat the [ __ ] out of me and hung me
from a gargoyle and each person that
comes in funny they're like and he's you
know obviously you get the joke it's
funny
and and obviously like the writers at
snl are
actually tenured genius legends so they
you know they punch up the script and
make it into like a real thing that
could work on camera
yeah they're second to none i mean that
that whole production that whole week
it's i i imagine it gives you a better
perspective too to appreciate something
like hot rods simply because you see the
world that andy sandberg was operating
and the bill hader was operating in and
it's you got to come up with all these
great ideas and they have to be ready to
go in five days yeah so with hot rod
it's like well this is a piece of cake
give us a little bit of money give us
some budget and we can make something
that's going to be a meaningful lasting
comedic hit even though the movie tanked
at the box office it's got this cult
following because everybody like you who
stumbles upon it on vod just ends up
falling in love with it and now you know
the 10 11 12 years on we're still
talking about hot rod because there's a
lot of comedies that came out that year
that sort of overshadowed it and you had
because you had these like the advent of
like super bad came out around that year
you had uh i think talladega knights was
around there bore out was around that
time so you had movies that were sort of
overshadowing it because they were box
office sensations but i mean for my
money i was talking about this before
you came on with our production team
brian and lucy like they just hot rod is
just one of those movies that has just
been in their lexicon and they still
consider it a classic yeah
it's it's different from all those other
movies i don't know if adam mckay worked
on that movie too but it's different
from those because of
andy's brand of comedy like i don't know
if you ever if you're familiar with the
movie pop star have you ever seen pop
star never stop never stopping never
stop never stopping like
he's just ridiculous or have you ever
seen his uh his commencement speech at
uh i don't think it was harvard it was
like princeton or yale or something like
that but uh yeah oh no he did it it was
at harvest i mean it was at harvard i
remember
i remember hearing about i don't know if
i've ever watched the whole thing but
it's probably on youtube i should catch
that he's a genius he's hilarious and
i'm pretty sure he's uh
i'm pretty sure that he's married to um
why am i forgetting her name right now
joanna newsom who's also a genius he
just has a baller lifestyle
have you ever been approached about
collabing with with lonely island at all
i mean if you know it seems like you all
would get along great you got an improv
background you're both you know you have
you have music
yeah no if i was ever approached by them
you would know because there'd be a song
there'd be a series of songs and collab
mixtapes and stuff going on no it's just
a rod sequel i would oh my god i would
do it in a second i actually tried out i
actually auditioned for the role that
chris redd plays in pop star and i
didn't know that it was i didn't know
that it was a andy sandberg movie i
didn't know what what was really going
on they kind of just give you uh your
size and you go in and read for a party
and you hear it's a comedy but
i'm glad chris redd got it because he
played it completely different than i
would have and he's hilarious and he's
also from chicago yeah right right yeah
meadows tim meadows to me talk about snl
legends that are underrated tim meadows
was the glue for that show for a long
time he steals that movie he steals pop
star for me yeah no he's he's uh he's he
does the same thing in um
another uh
music mockumentary or fake biopic uh
wall car at the dewey [ __ ] story
amazing i don't know what that has on
rotten tomatoes that's possibly one of
the funniest movies to ever be made and
it's another movie where tim meadows
steals the show he's uh i met him at snl
like i think the last time that i did it
this this past time was
i finally did double duty which is uh
you know
there's
i think less than 25 people that have
done it it's uh the the act of of
hosting and and being a guest
uh music performer and it's an
unbelievable work week you can't imagine
but uh
tim meadows came out to see me do that
and i got to meet him and it was one of
the coolest things no just to go back
i'm sure that people are going to who i
picked as like my snl legends everyone
from snl is a legend you know even the
people that were only on for a couple of
episodes all go on to do
amazing things yeah you gotta you you
were on the legacy show you you had an
impact and i have great news for you as
because i do want to ask you about
magnificent color uh coloring world
before we gotta get out of here walk
hard the dewey [ __ ] story chance we
finally did it
it's certified fresh there we go
it is 74
on the tomato meter so
we some things are undeniable
we'll tackle bulworth we'll tackle the
house we'll tackle hot rod but walk hard
congratulations we do not have any beef
with rotten tomatoes
for your movie and it doesn't seem like
the folks are divided about your movie
that once again just uh finished it i
think it was in theaters here for for
two weeks and it was in over 80 theaters
nationwide and now it's going to make
its way around the world which is just
so exciting it's magnificent coloring
world it's going to be in the uk and
ireland and canada releasing on
september 10th check it out on the big
screen i cannot encourage you all enough
to do that because
this is
tell us about the i hate starting like
this but tell us about the stage because
the stage is such a cool selling point
and it's such a
thing to witness in a movie theater yeah
the stage was the first idea i think
that's what actually the two first ideas
was one was sound i had seen a lot of
concert films or had concert films
in like a audio format like a you know
like a the cd of a of a live concert and
the audio of the stage is amazing
but the audi like the audience sound
isn't really there except for in between
songs you hear a little bit of claps but
like you know
hearing like a it sounds like a small
100 person audience clapping when
they're like in a stadium and it's just
because they don't you know there's
there's not the intention of actually
recording the audience and how loud they
sound when they scream or how loud they
sound when they sing together as like an
army of voices and you witness that in a
real live show but you don't get that
most of the time in concert films so the
first thing that i thought about was how
do we mic up the audience the second
thing was staging because the audience
is always parallel to the stage their
eyes are always fixed in one way
and i thought about the idea of doing a
multi-stage
concert which you know made me start
thinking about lighting and made me
think about
really the most important thing is how
do you keep everyone engaged what's
going on on these stages that makes it
makes it different and so
i designed this the stage format which
was five stages in a semicircle like
think of like a u almost
and then if you turn that you could turn
that u into a d if you put a long
row of bleachers at the other side so
there's like a hollow
middle of it where
that's basically camera world where i
could shoot all the angles that i needed
was a nine camera shoot
and
then
basically i just needed a way to to to
once i make my rounds not have to run
all the way back around so i
i had the idea to make a a stay at like
a floating stage a basically a dolly
stage where there's a camera fixed and i
could just step onto this dolly and go
from the stages to the farthest
left all the way across to the stage
that's the farthest right and kind of
just like
you know intentionally made each stage
kind of represent
a piece of my music so i don't want to
give away the whole thing because i know
there's people that still haven't got to
see it especially overseas but it's a
really cool
it's unique yeah it's inventive because
i remember when when you and i got a
chance to chat with jacqueline on on
twitter spaces we
you mentioned that you'd seen so many
documentaries and concert films and you
were inspired by them but it also does
show you what not to do
from it from an audience miking
standpoint but then also it just gives
you and ideas to say well what i'm
thinking has never been done before
because it is an experience that you've
never had when you go see a concert film
and so
it's it's fresh and it's unique and the
fact that i didn't realize that the
journey from the the taping to
theaters had been
four years but it was really well worth
it because there's a lot of people that
have talent but the you can tell how
much you care about your audience and
them getting to witness it the way that
you saw it in your head
totally yeah i mean like that's the
that's the joy of being an artist is
like
you get to create new things and get to
speak to people in a in the way that you
want to like in a
you know beautiful way to you and
i
have always loved film i think before i
even knew i loved music i loved movies
as we all do everybody especially if
you're a 90s kid
just like we're glued to the tv and i
you know above all love the theater
experience and so the idea of being able
to bring people out of their house to a
movie
to my music
engineered and
perfected
audibly but then on top of that shot by
jake schreier who's my favorite director
and then and then like i said getting
them to come out the house and
experience it on a giant screen with
this you know true surround sound
because surround sound in your house is
not real
that's a whole i could just that's a
whole thing but uh
being
in the position that i'm in being an
independent artist somebody that owns
their masters and
you know just having the autonomy that i
do
i was able to do something that hadn't
been done before i was able to fully
create from its inception
a
concert film a real movie and get it
into
the realest theater chain in the world
you know and yeah
and now it's all over there now it's
going to go all over the world now it's
it's going global and and i'm telling
you this because we're sort of marrying
the two movies that we're really here to
talk about today
i
had seen your movie first and then i saw
hot rod the next time you do one of
these chats i'm not saying it's out of
the realm of possibility to have andy
sandberg jump a bunch of buses like
right in the middle of the show we could
combine hot rod and magnificent coloring
world into one giant spectacle and call
it hot rod 2.
i'm not going to tell you that i'm going
to do it
because that would be a spoiler and i
want you to experience it in the
theaters and say
have you seen that meme it's from uh
it's from uh
i can't even remember the name of the
last tarantino movie but there's like
from uh once upon a time and honestly
about a time in hollywood oh yeah yeah
when leo's pointing yeah yeah that's
gonna be you in the theater when you see
that that dirt bike go from one stage to
the other
hey no no royalties necessary just do me
a favor and come back on the show
whenever you got beef with another movie
or the tomato meter more specifically as
far as way too high way too low a couple
quick questions before you get out of
here what's because i know you're you're
you're big on your hometown chicago
what's like the best
movie about chicago that you've ever
seen what's a chicago movie everybody
needs to check out
all right i'm just gonna shoot from the
hip instead of taking a long time
because
i'll take for everything about this i
have so many chicago movies the first
one the one that i would say that people
might not all agree with but i'm gonna
just throw it out there
barbershop
the entire barbershop series actually
ice cube
wrote and direct oh actually i don't
think he directed i think it's malcolm
malcolm d lee but
amazing movie with a lot of heart and
it's not so chicago-centric that it
feels phony or forced
it's just
a movie where there's like little pieces
of dialogue there's a scene where where
uh
where ice cube uh picks up ricky when
ricky's about to go
kill somebody i think and
uh he pulls over on the side of a bridge
and ricky throws his gun
into the into the river right before
they go see uh lester wallace
yeah
and
when ice cube is trying to like
you know give him the speech and
convince him to give up the life of
crime it sounds corny when i remember it
but like it was there's just this little
line where he says uh
where ricky's getting in the car and uh
he's like what you're doing with that
you're gonna throw your life away and
ricky goes man whatever just drop me off
on 79th i'm from 79th when i hear people
say that it's like especially in a movie
it just gives you you get a little
feeling and i just think it was just
like you know
it's just a real movie there's so many
there's a lot of movies though you know
coolly high what's another great movie
you just want that authentic chicago
feel because you can go you can go here
ferris bueller's day off ferris
bueller's day off has all the hallmarks
you got the sausage king of chicago you
got wrigley field in there blues
brothers i mean there's
there's a bunch of chicago movies but
barbershop is maybe the most important
movie for the success of standalone atms
because it taught everybody who thought
about stealing one how hard it actually
is to get the money out of them so it's
really not worth your time it's super
rare
anthony anderson and um i can't remember
laurence tate's brother's name but
they're they're uh they're trying to
carry the uh the it's great atm up the
stairs and they do and then they wait
for somebody and then they're coming
back down the stairs and the fat dude is
trying to pump the stairs i'm not gonna
ruin the movie for you no spoilers it's
just it's a great running gag throughout
barbershop and then you got the this the
spin-off the next cut then you have
beauty shop so it's it's a whole
franchise that does typify the
authenticity that you want of chicago in
movies so final question here chance and
then
we'll let you go
what's a current movie maybe maybe it's
a recent movie maybe it's one that you
just recently caught we always ask our
guests for a movie recommendation as
they say goodbye so besides hot rod and
besides definitely never ever bullworth
what is your movie recommendation for
all of our ketchup crew listeners
all right this is gonna sound very corny
okay
uh
i recently rewatched
the godfather series
yeah
and i'm here to deliver a hot take
that some people are not gonna be ready
for
the first godfather is better than the
second godfather
okay if you don't believe me watch
re-watch them both
and
i'll go farther than that to say that
vito corleone is a much
better don than michael was
okay
next time next time i'm on the show i'll
have a dissertation for you just to
explain it all but please please do i do
i do a show on uh on rotten tomatoes
called versus and it's just matching up
art and making it competitive i'm
writing an episode right now that is the
godfather franchise versus the sopranos
do you go godfather are you team
godfather you team sopranos which one
i'm gonna be honest i was eight years
old when the sopranos was coming on tv i
actually never watched it i tried to
watch it twice
and this is probably gonna make people
not value my opinion as much but [ __ ] it
i don't care i've never watched the
sopranos i never watched the wire and i
never watched sex in the city all these
hbo shows that came out in this like
time when they were creating
um
series dramatic series that were like
hour long premium
things like i was i was like i said i
was eight or nine years old so i didn't
watch him and then when you try and
re-watch him
you know there's always the pilot hump
like trying to watch a old show with a
pilot is giving you 50 000 names and
pieces of information that you don't
want to care about it's just tough but
yeah through and through the godfather
series is possibly uh the greatest film
series of all time and some and and two
the first two are the two of the
greatest movies ever created but again
just to stress this and hopefully
becomes a twitter you know debate the
first the first godfather is
just a far better movie it's obviously
way more [ __ ] streamlined you don't
have to go back and forth between two
completely different stories the whole
time you don't have a callous don that's
just like making dumbass decisions all
the time and i love michael i love
michael to death in the first movie but
in the second one none of his decisions
make sense uh
robert de niro's
veto story is
super anticlimactic and it's just
it uh it tears off and and it's a great
movie still
one of the greatest movies ever made and
to me the greatest sequel after the dark
knight but it's a uh
it it pales in comparison to the first
the first godfather you guys got to
rewatch the first godfather
there it is the godfather it's the hot
rod of dramas according to
chance the rapper who we really got
about five episodes worth the content
out of this this was so much fun to to
talk movies to talk music with you and
everything in between
again the movie
the chance the rapper
self-funded produced it himself
self-released it had a great run here in
the states and now people around the
world are going to get a chance to check
out magnificent coloring world and it is
in the uk it's in ireland and it's in
canada and going to more places soon
september 10th is when it drops in those
provinces slash countries
congratulations on all the success of
the movie it's been so much fun having
you on the show come back whenever you
want to chance you're always welcome
that rotten tomatoes is wrong absolutely
will thank you man
[Music]
and there you have it did i tell you all
that the guy loves movies i mean
chance the rapper's a great name he
might be chance the podcaster he seems
like he wants to be on this show just
about every week he might be coming for
my job and i'll be honest i'd still
listen to the show every week if i'm not
on it if i get to hear chance and jaclyn
talk about movies because he is
passionate he cares he puts a lot of
thought and detail into his opinions
about obviously music but also film and
once again his movie is now opening in
the uk ireland and canada on september
10th magnificent coloring world a
concert experience unlike any other
thanks to chance the rapper and thanks
again for being such a great sport and
just running the gamut of all different
kinds of movies during that conversation
he's truly great to talk to and i hope
we have him back again soon we love all
of our guests and our members of the
ketchup crew that's our fans here at
rotten tomatoes is wrong so before we
get out of here we are going to turn it
over to mailbag
[Music]
i do love that mailbag music so this is
from member of the ketchup crew two
members kevin and carla all right one of
them talks and the other one dictates
i'm not sure how it works with kevin and
carla but here we go we eagerly await
each release and it's a morning listen
on our boat as we're sailing the world
kevin and carla give me a call next time
this week's episode on the holiday was
enjoyed at anchor in bocas del toro
panama panama kevin and carla living the
dream right now thanks for taking us at
least our podcast along for the ride our
suggestion for a movie comes from shared
memories of it playing in the background
when we were first dating
miami vice
which is not the movie i thought i'd say
miami vice from 2006 is an amazing ride
with great music and dark brooding
scenes rotten tomatoes is so wrong with
a score of 46 percent come on who isn't
a i'm a fiend for mojitos
love the show kevin and carla p.s your
armageddon episode had us laughing
having spent a number of years
explaining technical terms to government
and business leader the it's the size of
texas mr president wine is exactly how
you would explain the size of the
asteroid to a president and i believe
the name of their ship their boat
is the sv gargoyle so if you're out
there around panama you see the sv
gargoyle give them a
i don't know what
do they have horns on boats i don't know
how sailing works kevin and carl but i
know you are doing a great job thank you
again for your support of the show
everybody who's out there listening
right now we love it when you email us
you can hit us up anytime rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com that's rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and you can also rate
review subscribe whatever your preferred
podcast way of listening encourages you
to do we encourage you to do that our
listenership is getting bigger and
better every week i imagine this one
probably had some ears and eyes on it so
thank you for all your support to every
member of our catch-up crew
that's going to do it for today's show i
missed jaclyn but i had a great time
talking with chance the rapper thank you
producee lucy and brian perez and next
week
oh this is gonna be an exciting one
because we're talking
dc eu you wanna guess the movie
aquaman
starring jason momoa as the title
character you talk about a lot of people
popping into hot rod a lot of folks show
up in aquaman is rotten tomatoes wrong
about aquaman we're gonna get into all
that and more next week right here on
rotten tomatoes is wrong for the whole
gang here i'm mark ellis jacqueline come
back soon but enjoy tell your ride we'll
talk to you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you